we have a problem in crypto a few days
ago when i released my scam rewind 2021
some of the people mentioned in the
video got very mad that i included them
they said they weren't scammers they had
merely promoted a scam but they
themselves were innocent now i don't
want to get into who it was because it's
really not the first time i've heard of
this multiple times i've heard the
excuse from influencers
hey
i didn't scam anybody i just promoted
the scam to all my followers i just
didn't know what i was doing and
everyone ended up getting hurt but that
doesn't make me a bad guy in other words
the defense is i'm so dumb i can't be
held accountable for my actions sort of
like the insanity defense but for
influencers and to some extent that does
make sense crypto is complicated
definitely too complicated for our
lawmakers who don't even seem to
understand the very basics now
the number one threat to crypto
currency is crypto
bitcoin could be depl displaced by ether
which could be first placed by dodge it
should be placed by a hamster coin
and then there's cobra coin and what
could [ __ ] coin do to crypto coin wait
i take that back he does sound like he's
onto something with this mongoose coin
and i tell you not to invest in it but
of course people already have but in all
seriousness today i want to begin
educating people on how to evaluate new
cryptocurrencies so nobody can tell me
oh i didn't know it was a scam hopefully
this will cover some of the basics of
some red flags you can look for
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a coffee
zilla christmas don't forget to pump the
stock today of course we're talking
about how to evaluate stuff so let's
let's begin with a hypothetical let's
say my stock market strategy just got
killed by twitter and i need to move to
crypto i was insider trading based on
nancy pelosi's insider trading and both
of us were killing the market but
suddenly my strategy's gone now what do
we do well one option is to swing to the
other side of the aisle and jump into
crypto with candace owens she says she's
all in this coin called let's go branded
now if i'm dumb i would say hey that's a
meme it's an influencer pushing a meme
meme coins do well i will invest all my
money but wait this is the moment we can
flex our investigation skills what is
this coin is it a scam and how do we
know it's a scam before it scams us well
there are some key indicators i want to
explain to you guys about whether
something is a rug pull or not and this
is not an exhaustive process this is the
bare minimum you should do let's start
with the promotion does candace owens
know anything about crypto no so it's
probably a paid post and upon further
inspection even the screenshot itself is
pretty dishonest from the picture that
was posted it looks like the coin is
ranked 326
but in actuality the screenshot has been
cropped very carefully in actuality the
coin is actually ranked in the three
thousands so
that's bad but next we're going to talk
about how much liquidity does this
influencer token have now what is
liquidity well most people are used to
talking about crypto in terms of market
caps and from that you'd see that let's
go brandon has about a 280 million
dollar market cap now that sounds great
sounds like a huge project but there's a
problem that's not actually how much
money is in the project if you want to
know how much money actually protects
you from this thing going to zero we
have to look at something called
liquidity pulse i won't bore you guys
too much with the details because i know
a lot of people don't care but prices of
coins like this are usually determined
by decentralized market makers like
uniswap i'll speed up a little bit
because i know i'm boring people um if
we use dextools or dbank we can
basically find that in the case of let's
go brandon the amount of actual money
that is in this project is roughly three
million dollars in ethereum that's right
you think you're invested in a 300
million dollar project in actuality it's
much closer to a three million dollar
project and why does this matter well
you're at risk of a rug pull now a rug
pool is when somebody who owns a lot of
the coins sells it all at the same time
and the price craters to zero and now
the market oh
oh
it went to zero
and to understand what your risk is
let's look at the next part of our
investigation who owns this coin we can
find this out by putting in their smart
contract into ether scan and clicking to
the holders tab which brings us here and
we find out here that the top 100
holders own 97
of this coin in other words most of the
holders are whales and why that matters
is that they can easily siphon off all
that three million dollars of value
basically at any time like i did some
quick napkin calculation and even if
just the number one holder who currently
holds 22
of this coin even if he just sells all
his tokens he would walk away with 96
of the total money and the same is
basically true of a lot of these other
large holders so if you're buying this
coin you're just sort of hoping that all
these people
don't take the money and run and that's
really bad oh and to add insult to entry
this coin isn't original it doesn't have
a white paper and there are 64 other
coins currently exactly like it
and so the conclusion well you're going
to get wrecked if you jump in this coin
probably and if you're candace owens
you've just sold out your followers and
sentenced them to near certain financial
ruin by promoting this coin as a funny
meme to own the libs the only people
candace owens is actually owning are the
people who buy this now i don't care if
you're democrat or conservative i don't
want to see anyone get scammed my point
here showing you this is that
influencers of all shapes and sizes
political or not are promoting this
stuff with absolutely no idea what
they're doing and hurting people in the
process for a quick paycheck but okay
now that you know a lot of these
political people are grifting on you you
know the influencers are grifting on you
the last thing i want to discuss is what
makes a good project right what's
positive well obviously having a long
track record is obviously very good you
also want a large liquidity pool and
distributed ownership so you're not at
risk of a rug pool and then i think the
biggest thing guys the number one thing
at the end of the day is just that these
things have utility ladies and gentlemen
stop investing in these meme coins
please they only are getting traction
because you guys keep investing in them
and it drives me absolutely insane i
mean look that coin that we just looked
at millions of dollars have already been
poured into it but ultimately it's one
of 64 identical tokens that token is
never going in anywhere and at the end
of the day guys you should just only
invest in projects that you actually
understand and will have a real world
value in the future that's the only way
they will survive so yeah if you just
apply that basic common sense you're
gonna save yourself a lot of time and
money and the same goes for influencers
if you're promoting something that's
just based on a meme you're gonna wreck
your followers and you can't claim
ignorance for it guys you can't claim
ignorance not anymore we've already
we've gone through it now um so i hope
everyone learned something i hope that
made a little bit of sense just use
tools like etherscan dex tools dbank to
try to figure out what's going on under
the hood if you spend a little time
there you're gonna save yourself a lot
of money thanks for watching i
appreciate you guys and subscribe if you
haven't already we're trying to save the
kids this month all right i'll see ya
this part of the story